Let me show you. So this is what the sleeves look like. Off.
They really are just a crochet.
There's no give. This is like just straight cotton yarn.
It does keep me warm like a blanket.
It really. I mean,
you're wearing a crochet blanket.
It just also has arms like it.
So the arms are a little baggy,
you know what I mean? There's no give,
but they are big. They also,
for me, I'm a little bit tall.
They don't come all the way to my wrist,
do you know what I mean? It's a little short,
so sometimes I even just do this. It.
For me, I'm wearing it cause it feels like it's a blanket.
But yeah,
that's what the arms look like.
And I also pull it up a little bit to make it feel like.
And fold it. But the arms can be.
I don't know. I hope I'm showing you the arms
good for me. They don't come all the way down.
I don't know. Okay.
I hope that's helping.
Like, you can pull it.
I can go like that. But then I kind of.
And that's when it all kind of fell off my shoulder a little bit, so.
But no, there's no flexibility.
It's literally like just straight cotton yarn,
you know what I mean? It is just.
There ain't much to it. There's no.
It's stretching because it's a crochet thing,
you know what I mean? Because it's just Like,
widening the pattern, but the fabric itself does not have give. No.
I super hope that helps.